Tim Jaccard is full of stories that from anybody else would not be believable. For instance, this girl, Katie Longendyke, who had no idea she was pregnant until the day she gave birth.
蒂姆·雅卡德（Tim Jaccard）的故事总是充满了不可思议的细节，换作别人讲，你可能根本不会相信。比如这个女孩凯蒂·朗恩戴克（Katie Longendyke），她在分娩当天之前完全不知道自己怀孕了。
She was actually taking birth control pills during the entire pregnancy and was unaware of it. So she was in what we refer to as denial. Total denial on this pregnancy. She started having abdominal pain. She says she never felt the baby kicking ever.
事实上，她在整个怀孕期间一直在服用避孕药，对此毫不知情。所以她处于我们所说的“否认期”。对这次怀孕完全处于否认状态。她开始感到腹痛，她说自己从未感觉到过胎动。
And then there was the 15-year-old in Staten Island who kept her entire pregnancy secret from her parents.
还有斯塔滕岛那个15岁的女孩，她对父母隐瞒了整个孕期。
And then she actually gave birth in her bedroom by herself with her mother and father sleeping at the other end of the house. She hid that pregnancy straight through. And she handed the baby off to us on the side of the building and told us to leave. And we disappeared with the baby.
然后她竟然在自己的卧室里独自生下了孩子，当时她的父母就在屋子的另一头睡觉。她把怀孕的事隐瞒到了最后。她在大楼侧面把孩子交给了我们，叫我们离开。然后我们就带着孩子消失了。
Tim got into the business of rescuing babies years ago. He was a medical officer in an ambulance. And he was sickened by the number of one-day-old babies that they would be called out for, babies that had been killed or left to die. In 1998, he helped write the country's first safe-haven law that allows women to deliver their babies anonymously and relinquish them without going to prison for abandoning their kids. He started a hotline that hooks women up with free prenatal care and delivery, and adoption services if they don't want to raise the baby.
蒂姆多年前就开始从事拯救婴儿的工作了。他曾是一名救护车医疗官员。他被当时出诊时见到的那些刚出生一天的婴儿的数量震惊了，这些孩子要么被杀害，要么被遗弃等死。1998年，他协助起草了该国第一部《安全港法》，允许女性匿名分娩并将婴儿交给相关机构，而无需因遗弃罪入狱。他开通了一条热线，为那些不想抚养孩子的女性提供免费的产前护理、分娩及收养服务。
And it's had an effect. In New York where he operates, he says the number of dead babies that they find in a year has dropped from 16 back when he began to 3 nowadays. That 3 still bothers him, though. That there's still some mothers he can't reach.
这确实产生了影响。在他工作的纽约，他说每年发现死亡婴儿的数量已经从他开始时的16个下降到了如今的3个。不过，这3个数字仍然让他感到难过，因为还有一些母亲是他无法触及的。
She called the crisis center, got on the phone. She was ready to give birth soon. I told her that we would come and help her. And I was supposed to meet her at a Burger King. And I waited for a good two and a half hours for her.
她给危机中心打了电话，接通了。她很快就要分娩了。我告诉她，我们会去帮她。我本该在一家汉堡王和她见面。我足足等了她两个半小时。
I had the cell phone number of her. I called her on the cell phone, called her back a couple of times. And there was no answer. I told her I'm waiting for her. I'm not going to leave. You could go back, come. I'm still here. And after two and a half hours, she never called.
我有她的手机号码。我用手机给她打过电话，回拨过好几次。没人接。我告诉她我在等她。我不会离开。你可以回来，过来吧。我还在那儿。两个半小时后，她始终没打来。
And two days later, there was a baby found in a dumpster right near, in that neighborhood over there. So I was just wondering whether or not-- was it this girl, or was it not this girl? We don't know. And we never will know.
两天后，在附近那个社区的垃圾箱里发现了一个婴儿。所以我一直在想，那到底是这个女孩的孩子，还是不是？我们不知道。而且永远也不会知道。
So-- I just don't understand why she didn't come. Did I say something wrong? Was I too aggressive? I even asked her if she was willing to meet with a woman rather than me, with a man. She just didn't show up.
所以我……我实在不明白她为什么没来。是我说错什么了吗？是我太激进了吗？我甚至问过她是否愿意去见一位女性而不是我（一个男人）。她就是没出现。
OK, you see Gabriel. Gabriel Hope, Christina Hope. We have Jonathan and Matthew, Holly Hope.
好了，你看，加布里埃尔（Gabriel）。加布里埃尔·霍普（Gabriel Hope）、克里斯蒂娜·霍普（Christina Hope）。我们有乔纳森（Jonathan）和马修（Matthew），还有霍莉·霍普（Holly Hope）。
And this is just rows and rows.
这一排排的全是。
And rows. We have--
一排又一排。我们有……
One, two, three, four. How many--
一、二、三、四。有多少个……
84 babies buried here at this site here.
84个婴儿埋葬在这里。
At Holy Rood Cemetery, Tim has arranged for funeral plots for the babies that he has not been able to save. The strangest thing about these little grave markers is that there's just one date beside each name. The date of birth is the date of death. Whoever finds the baby chooses a first name. Hope is always given as the last name.
在圣罗德公墓，蒂姆为他没能救下的婴儿安排了墓地。这些小墓碑最奇怪的地方在于，每个名字旁边只有一个日期。出生日期就是死亡日期。无论谁发现婴儿，都会为他们取一个名字。姓氏一律用“霍普”（Hope，意为希望）。
Tim says that he used to think about it a lot, all the kids that he couldn't save. But now he does a kind of moral calculation. He's at least able to give them a decent burial, he thinks. And news of each death gives him press, which leads to more pregnant moms coming forward to hand over their babies.
蒂姆说他过去常想这些事，想那些他没能救下的孩子。但现在他进行了一种道德计算。他认为，至少他能让他们入土为安。而每起死亡的新闻都会为他带来媒体曝光，进而促使更多怀孕的母亲站出来把孩子交给他。
Nicholas Hope, for instance-- we had four birth mothers call because of Nicholas Hope. He was found on top of a trash can in Hicksville Train Station. But through his death, we had four birth mothers call.
比如尼古拉斯·霍普（Nicholas Hope），我们就接到了四位生母因为尼古拉斯·霍普的报道而打来的电话。他在希克斯维尔火车站的一个垃圾桶顶上被发现。但通过他的死亡，我们获得了四位母亲的求助。
Where's he?
他在哪儿？
Nicholas Hope, right here. November 27 of last year, in winter.
尼古拉斯·霍普，就在这儿。去年的11月27日，在冬天。
This math, the four babies saved for the one that was lost, it's comforting to Tim, as are the photos on a bulletin board in his office-- there's got to be 100 of those shots-- of babies that he's saved, some of them now grown into little kids, smiling at the camera.
这种算术，每失去一个孩子能挽救四个，这对蒂姆来说是一种慰藉，就像他办公室公告板上的照片一样——那里肯定有100多张——都是他救下的孩子，有些已经长成了小孩，对着镜头微笑。
Which brings us to today's program. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show, Who Can You Save? Stories of people making this kind of life and death calculation. Act one of our show today, Kill One, Save Five. Act two, Rescue You, Rescue Me. Act three, The Murderer. Stay with us.
这就把我们带到了今天的节目。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天在我们的节目中，你能拯救谁？关于人们进行这种生死计算的故事。我们节目的第一幕，杀一个，救五个。第二幕，拯救你，拯救我。第三幕，谋杀者。请继续收听。
Act One. So how do we make these moral calculations in our lives? What is happening literally in our brains, really? Well, my favorite new show on public radio these days, a show called Radiolab , took up that question not long ago.
第一幕。那么，我们生活中是如何进行这些道德计算的呢？我们的大脑里究竟在发生什么？嗯，我最近最喜欢的公共广播新节目《放射性实验室》（Radiolab），不久前探讨了这个问题。
Radiolab is one of these shows that's still not on everywhere. And in lots of places, it's on at weird times. And lots of people haven't heard it. Chances are maybe you have never heard it. And so we asked the hosts of Radiolab , Jad Abumrad and Robert Krulwich, we asked them to let us excerpt some of what they said about this question. Here they are.
《放射性实验室》就是那种还没在各地普及的节目。在很多地方，它的播出时间很奇怪。很多人还没听过。你很可能从来没听过。所以我们请《放射性实验室》的主持人贾德·阿布姆拉德（Jad Abumrad）和罗伯特·克鲁尔维奇（Robert Krulwich），请他们让我们摘录了一些关于这个问题的讨论。他们来了。
Everybody knows that sometimes you feel something is right, sometimes you feel something is wrong. We want to know-- where does that feeling begin? Where does it come from? How old is it?
每个人都知道，有时你觉得某件事是对的，有时你觉得是错的。我们想知道，这种感觉是从哪里开始的？它是从哪儿来的？它有多古老？
Can  we get started, please?
我们可以开始了吗，拜托？
OK, OK. I was just going on a bit.
好吧，好吧。我刚才稍微扯远了一点。
Why don't we start with two morality thought experiments? Are you with me?
为什么我们不从两个道德思想实验开始呢？你们准备好了吗？
Begrudgingly, yes.
不情愿地，准备好了。
This is a famous problem. It's been floating around forever. There are two parts to this problem. And you're going to have to make a choice at the end of each one.
这是一个著名的问题。它流传了很久。这个问题有两个部分。在每个部分结束时，你都必须做出选择。
Each one-- what? You mean you're going to tell me a story?
每个部分……什么？你是说你要给我讲故事吗？
Yeah, I'm going to tell you a story. And you're going to make a choice. Part one, you ready?
是的，我要讲一个故事。然后你要做出选择。第一部分，准备好了吗？
Yeah.
准备好了。
All right. You're near some train tracks. Go there in your mind. There are five workers on the tracks, working. They've got their backs turned to the trolley which is coming in the distance.
好的。你在铁轨附近。在脑海中去到那个地方。有五个工人在铁轨上工作。他们的背对着远方开来的电车。
You mean they're repairing the tracks.
你是说他们在修理铁轨。
They are repairing the tracks.
他们正在修理铁轨。
This is unbeknownst to them, the trolley is approaching?
他们对正在靠近的电车一无所知？
They don't see it. You can't shout to them. And if you do nothing, here's what will happen. [FIVE PEOPLE SCREAMING AS A TRAIN HITS THEM] Five workers will die.
他们看不见。你没法向他们大喊。如果你什么都不做，接下来会发生什么？[五个人被火车撞击时发出的尖叫声] 五个工人会死。
Oh my God! That was a horrible experience. I don't want that to happen to them.
天哪！那真是一次可怕的经历。我不希望这种事发生在他们身上。
No you don't. But you have a choice. You can do A, nothing. Or B, it so happens next to you is a lever. Pull the lever and the trolley will jump onto some side tracks where there is only one person working. [ONE PERSON SCREAMING AS A TRAIN HITS HIM]
不，你当然不希望。但你有一个选择。你可以做A，什么都不做。或者B，巧的是你身边有一个杠杆。拉动杠杆，电车就会跳到另一条侧轨上，那里只有一个工人在工作。[一个人被火车撞击时发出的尖叫声]
So if the trolley goes on the second track, it will kill the one guy.
所以如果电车开上第二条轨道，它会杀死那个人。
Yeah, so there's your choice. Do you kill one man by pulling a lever? Or do you kill five men by doing nothing?
是的，这就是你的选择。你是通过拉动杠杆杀死一个人，还是通过什么都不做杀死五个人？
Well, I'm going to pull the lever.
嗯，我会拉动杠杆。
Naturally. All right. Here's part two. You're standing near some train tracks. Five guys are on the tracks, just as before. And there is the trolley coming like before.
很自然。好吧。这是第二部分。你站在一些铁轨附近。五个家伙像刚才一样在铁轨上。电车也像之前那样开过来。
I hear the train coming. The same five guys are working on the track?
我听到火车的声音了。同样的五个家伙在铁轨上工作？
Same five guys.
同样的五个家伙。
Backs to the train? They can't see it?
背对着火车？他们看不见吗？
Yeah, yeah. Exactly. However, I'm going to make a couple of changes. Now you're standing on a foot bridge that passes over the tracks. You're looking down onto the tracks. There's no lever anywhere to be seen. Except next to you, there is a guy.
是的，是的。完全正确。不过，我要做几个改动。现在你站在横跨铁轨的人行天桥上。你在俯视轨道。没有任何杠杆。但你旁边有一个家伙。
What do you mean there's a guy?
你说的有一个家伙是什么意思？
A large guy, large individual standing next to you on the bridge, looking down with you over the tracks. And you realize, wait, I can save those five workers if I push this man, give him a little tap. [ONE PERSON SCREAMING AS HE FALLS FROM A BRIDGE] He'll land on the tracks, and--
一个大块头，一个大个子站在你旁边的桥上，和你一起俯瞰轨道。你意识到，等等，如果我推这个人一把，给他一点力，我就能救那五个工人。[一个人从桥上落下时的尖叫声] 他会掉在铁轨上，然后……
He stops the train!
他挡住了火车！
Right.
对。
Oh man, I'm not going to do that! I'm not going to do that.
天哪，我才不会那样做！我绝不会那样做。
But surely you realize that the math is the same.
但你肯定意识到数学逻辑是一样的。
You mean I'll save four people this way?
你是说我这样能多救四个人？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, but this time I'm pushing the guy. Are you insane? No.
是啊，但这回是我去推那个人。你疯了吗？不。
All right, here's the thing. If you ask people these questions-- and we did, starting with the first, is it OK to kill one man to save five using a lever-- 9 out of 10 people will say--
好吧，关键在于。如果你问人们这些问题——我们也问了，先从第一个开始，为了救五个而拉杠杆杀死一个人是可以的吗——十分之九的人会说……
Yes.
可以。
Yeah.
没错。
But if you ask them, is it OK to kill one man to save five by pushing the guy, 9 out of 10 people will say--
但如果你问他们，为了救五个而推人去死是可以的吗，十分之九的人会说……
No.
不。
No. Never.
不。永远不行。
No.
不。
It is practically universal.
这几乎是普遍的。
Educational level, no effect. Male versus female, no effect.
受教育程度没有影响。男性还是女性，没有影响。
That's Marc Hauser, Professor at Harvard. He actually posed the trolley scenarios to hundreds of thousands of people on the internet and found the same thing. Everyone agrees. But then he took it a step further and asked them why? Why is murder-- because that's what it is-- why is murder OK when you're pulling a lever, but not OK when you're pushing the guy? And what he found is that consistently, people have no clue.
那是马克·豪瑟（Marc Hauser），哈佛大学教授。他实际上在互联网上向成千上万的人提出了这些电车情景，发现结果是一样的。每个人都同意。但他更进一步，问他们为什么？为什么谋杀——因为这就是谋杀——为什么拉杠杆杀人是可以的，而推人去死就不行？他发现，人们一直都说不出所以然。
People have no clue. They don't understand what drove their judgments, which were completely spontaneous and automatic and immediate. And once they appreciate the dilemma that they're now in, of lack of consistency, the whole thing basically begins to unravel.
人们一头雾水。他们不明白是什么驱动了他们的判断，这些判断完全是自发的、自动的和即时的。而一旦他们意识到自己现在陷入了缺乏一致性的困境，整个事情基本上就开始瓦解了。
The pulling the lever to save the five, I don't know. That feels better than pushing the one to save the five. But I don't really know why. So there's a good moral quandary for you.
拉杠杆救那五个，我不知道。那感觉比推一个人去救五个要好。但我真的不知道为什么。所以，这就是一个很好的道德困境。
And if, as we said in the beginning, having a moral sense is a unique and special human quality, then maybe we-- us two humans anyway, you and me-- should at least inquire as to why this happens. And I happened to have met somebody who has a hunch.
如果正如我们一开始所说，拥有道德感是一种独特而特殊的人类品质，那么也许我们——至少我们这两个人类，你和我——应该至少探究一下为什么会发生这种情况。碰巧我认识一个人，他有个预感。
He's a young guy at Princeton University, wild curly hair, bit of mischief in his eye. His name is Josh Greene.
他是普林斯顿大学的一个年轻人，长着一头狂野的卷发，眼神里透着一丝调皮。他的名字叫乔什·格林（Josh Greene）。
Alrighty.
好的。
And he spent the last few years trying to figure out where this inconsistency comes from.
过去几年他一直试图弄清楚这种不一致性从何而来。
How do people make this judgment? Forget whether or not these judgments are right or wrong. Just what's going on in the brain that makes people distinguish so naturally and intuitively between these two cases, which from an actuarial point of view are very, very, very similar if not identical?
人们是如何做出这种判断的？先不管这些判断是对是错。单看大脑中发生了什么，使人们如此自然和直观地区分这两种情况，而从精算角度来看，这两者非常、非常、非常相似，甚至相同？
Josh is, by the way, a philosopher and a neuroscientist. So this gives him special powers. He doesn't sort of sit back in a chair, smoke a pipe, and think, now why do you have these differences? He said, no, I would like to look inside people's heads. Because in our heads, we may find clues as to where these feelings of revulsion or acceptance come from. In our brains.
顺便说一下，乔什既是哲学家又是神经科学家。这赋予了他特殊的能力。他不是那种坐在椅子里抽着烟，思考着“为什么会有这些差异”的人。他说，不，我想看看人们的脑子里。因为在我们的脑子里，也许能找到这些排斥或接受的感觉来源。在我们的脑子里。
So we're here in the control room. We basically just see--
所以我们现在在控制室。我们基本上只看到……
And it just so happens that in the basement of Princeton, there was this-- um, well--
恰好在普林斯顿的地下室，有这个……嗯，好……
--big circular thing.
……一个巨大的圆形装置。
Yeah, it looks kind of like an airplane engine.
是的，看起来有点像飞机引擎。
180,000-pound brain scanner. What Josh does is he invites people into this room, has them lie down on what is essentially a cot on rollers, and he rolls them into the machine. Their heads are braced so they're stuck in there.
一台18万磅重的大脑扫描仪。乔什所做的就是邀请人们进入这个房间，让他们躺在本质上是一张带滚轮的简易床上，然后把他们推进机器里。他们的头被固定住，所以他们动弹不得。
Have you ever done this?
你做过这个吗？
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Several times.
哦，是的。是的。好几次。
And then he tells them stories. He tells them the same two trolley tales that you told before. And then at the very instant that they're deciding, whether I should push the lever or whether I should push the man, at that instant, the scanner snaps pictures of their brains. And what he found in those pictures was frankly a little startling. He showed us some.
然后他给他们讲故事。他讲了你之前讲的那两个电车故事。然后就在他们做决定的那一瞬间，无论是应该拉杠杆还是应该推人，在那一刻，扫描仪拍下了他们大脑的照片。而他在这些照片中发现的东西坦率地说有点令人震惊。他向我们展示了一些。
I'll show you some stuff. OK.
我给你看点东西。好的。
The picture that I'm looking at is a brain looked at, I guess, from the top down?
我看着的这张照片是一个人脑，我猜是从上往下看的？
Yeah. It's the top down and sort of sliced like a deli slicer.
是的。从上往下，像切熟食一样切片。
And the first slide that he showed me was a human brain being asked the question, would you pull the lever? And the answer in most cases was yes.
他给我看的第一张幻灯片是一个人脑在被问到“你会拉杠杆吗”时的反应。在大多数情况下，答案是肯定的。
Yeah, I'd pull the lever.
是的，我会拉杠杆。
When the brain's saying yes, you'd see little peanut-shaped spots of yellow.
当大脑说“是”的时候，你会看到花生形状的小黄点。
It's this little guy right here. And these two guys right there.
就是这里的这个小家伙。还有那里的那两个。
The brain was being active in these places. And oddly enough, whenever people said yes--
大脑在这些部位变得活跃。奇怪的是，每当人们说“是”的时候……
Yes.
是。
--to the lever question, the very same pattern lit up. Then he showed me another slide. This was a slide of a brain saying no--
……对拉杠杆的问题，同样的模式就会亮起。然后他又给我看了另一张幻灯片。这是一张大脑说“不”的幻灯片……
No, I would not push the man.
不，我不会推那个人。
--I will not push the large man. And in this picture--
……我不会推那个大个子。而在那张照片里……
This one we're looking at here, this--
我们现在看的这一张，这个……
--it was a totally different constellation of regions that lit up.
……亮起的区域是完全不同的组合。
--this is the no, no, no crowd?
这个就是“不，不，不”那一派？
I think this is part of the no, no, no crowd.
我想这是“不，不，不”派的一部分。
So when people answer yes to the lever question, there are places in their brain which glow?
所以当人们对拉杠杆问题回答“是”时，他们大脑中有一些地方会发光？
Right. But when they answer no, I will not push the man, then you get a completely different part of the brain lighting up.
对。但当他们回答“不，我不会推那个人”时，大脑完全不同的部分会亮起来。
Even though the questions are basically the same?
即使问题基本是一样的？
Mhm.
嗯。
Well, what does that mean? And what does Josh make of this?
那么，这意味着什么？乔什是怎么看待这个的？
Well, he has a theory about this.
嗯，他对此有一个理论。
Well, a theory not proven. But I think that this is what I think the evidence suggests.
嗯，一个未经证实的理论。但我认为证据支持这一点。
He suggests that the human brain doesn't hum along like one big unified system. Instead he says, maybe in your brain, in every brain, you'll find little, warring tribes, little sub-groups. One that is doing the logical counting kind of thing.
他认为人脑并不是像一个统一的大系统那样运作。相反，他说，也许在你的大脑里，在每个人的大脑里，都有一些互相争斗的小部落，小群体。其中一个在做逻辑计算之类的事情。
You've got one part of the brain that says, huh, five lives versus one life? Wouldn't it be better to save five versus one?
你大脑里有一部分说，“嗯，五条生命对一条生命？救五个比救一个更好，不是吗？”
And that's the part that would glow when you answer yes, I'd pull the lever.
这就是当你回答“是，我会拉杠杆”时发光的部分。
Yeah, I'll pull the lever.
是的，我会拉杠杆。
But there's this other part of the brain which really, really doesn't like personally killing another human being, and gets very upset at the fat man case, and shouts in effect--
但大脑还有另一部分，真的、非常不喜欢亲自杀死另一个人，在大个子的案例中会变得非常不安，实际上在呐喊……
No!
不！
It understands it on that level, and says--
它在那个层面上理解了，并且说……
No!
不！
--no, bad, don't do.
……不，坏的，不要做。
No, I don't think I could push--
不，我想我推不动……
No.
不。
No. Never.
不。永远不行。
--a person.
……一个人。
No.
不。
Instead of having one system that just sort of churns out the answer and bing, we have multiple systems that give different answers. And they duke it out. And hopefully, out of that competition comes morality.
我们不是只有一个系统来输出答案，我们有多个系统给出不同的答案。它们打了一架。希望通过这种竞争能产生道德。
This is not a trivial discovery, that you struggle to find right and wrong depending upon what part of your brain is shouting the loudest. This is like bleachers morality.
这是一个不小的发现，你苦苦寻找对与错，取决于你大脑的哪个部分喊得最响。这就像看台上的道德。
Do you buy this?
你相信这个吗？
Uh, you know, I just don't know. I've always kind of suspected that a sense of right and wrong is mostly stuff that you get from your mom and your dad and from experience, that it's culturally learned, for the most part. Josh is kind of a radical in this respect. He thinks it's biological, I mean deeply biological. That somehow we inherit from the deep past a sense of right and wrong that's already in our brains from the get-go, before mom and dad.
呃，你知道，我真的不知道。我一直怀疑对错感主要来自你的父母和经验，大部分是文化学习来的。乔什在这方面算是个激进分子。他认为这是生物学的，我是说深刻的生物学。某种程度上，我们从深层过去继承了一种对错感，在我们出生时、在父母之前就已经存在于我们的大脑中了。
Our primate ancestors, before we were full-blown humans, had intensely social lives. And so deep in our brain, we have what you might call basic primate morality. And basic primate morality doesn't understand things like tax evasion. But it does understand things like pushing your buddy off of a cliff.
我们的灵长类祖先，在我们成为完全的人类之前，就有非常强烈的社会生活。所以在大脑深处，有我们所谓的“基本灵长类道德”。基本的灵长类道德不理解“逃税”之类的东西。但它确实理解“把你的伙伴推下悬崖”之类的东西。
Oh, so you're thinking then that the man on the bridge-- that I'm on the bridge next to the large man, and I have hundreds of thousands of years of training in my brain that says, don't murder the large man.
哦，所以你是想说，桥上的那个人——我站在桥上，旁边是大个子，我大脑里有几十万年的训练告诉我，“别谋杀那个大个子”。
Right. Whereas--
对。而……
And even if I'm thinking, if I murder the large man, I'm going save five lives and only kill the one man, that there's something deeper down there that says, don't murder the large man?
即使我在想，如果我杀了那个大个子，我就能救五条命，只牺牲那一个人，在那深处还是有东西在说，“别谋杀那个大个子”？
Right. In that case, I think it's a pretty easy case. Even though it's five versus one, in that case, people just go with what we might call the inner-chimp. But there are other--
对。在这种情况下，我认为是一个非常简单的案例。即使是五对一，人们也只是顺从于我们所谓的“内在黑猩猩”。但还有其他……
Inner-chimp is your unfortunate way of describing an act of deep goodness.
“内在黑猩猩”是你描述一种深刻善良行为的不太恰当的方式。
Right, well, that's what's interesting.
好吧，这很有趣。
Thou shalt not-- it's the Ten Commandments, for God's-- inner-chimp!
“不可……”这是《十诫》啊，看在上帝的份上……内在黑猩猩！
Right. Well, what's interesting is that we think of basic human morality as being handed down from on high. And it's probably better to say that it was handed up from below.
好吧，有趣的是，我们认为基本的人类道德是从天而降的。说它是从下往上构建的可能更准确。
Jad Abumrad and Robert Krulwich of Radiolab. That was produced by Jad and Ellen Horne. Go to their website. Download their shows for free. You will not be disappointed. radiolab.org.
《放射性实验室》的贾德·阿布姆拉德和罗伯特·克鲁尔维奇。由贾德和艾伦·霍恩（Ellen Horne）制作。访问他们的网站。免费下载他们的节目。你不会失望的。radiolab.org。
Act Two, Rescue You, Rescue Me. Well, now we move from saving strangers from an onrushing train to saving strangers by taking a new job. There are these jobs that are up for grabs. And they're all about helping people. But the catch is-- and there is a catch-- they all come with what the official job descriptions call danger pay. Before your first day, you're trained on how to handle a gun, how to do evasive driving, including busting through roadblocks. These are US government jobs, civilian jobs, doing reconstruction in Iraq.
第二幕，拯救你，拯救我。好吧，现在我们从从疾驰的火车下拯救陌生人，转向通过接受一份新工作来拯救陌生人。有这些工作岗位可供申请。它们都是关于帮助人们的。但条件是——确实有条件——它们都带有官方职位描述中所说的“危险津贴”。在第一天上班之前，你会接受如何使用枪支、如何进行规避驾驶（包括冲破路障）的训练。这些都是美国政府的工作，文职工作，在伊拉克进行重建。
And the state department is having so much trouble filling these positions that in February, the head of the agency, Condoleezza Rice, told Congress that it was too hard. She was going to have to get Army Reservists to do 40% of the open jobs, 129 positions. And when a 51-year-old father of three, Randy Frescoln, signed up for one of these civilian jobs, his wife did a very simple moral calculation.
国务院在填补这些职位方面遇到了很大的麻烦，以至于在二月份，该机构负责人康多莉扎·赖斯（Condoleezza Rice）告诉国会，这太难了。她不得不让陆军预备役人员来承担40%的空缺工作，即129个职位。当51岁、三个孩子的父亲兰迪·弗雷斯科伦（Randy Frescoln）报名参加其中一份文职工作时，他的妻子做了一个非常简单的道德计算。
Keep in mind, I'm a volunteer. I was not a soldier. And I did not have to go. I was a pure volunteer. And I asked my wife. She said she could not understand why someone would volunteer to go to a war zone, put their life in risk to help people we don't really care about. And that's harsh, but this is what she's saying.
记住，我是志愿者。我不是士兵。我没必要去。我纯粹是志愿者。我问我妻子。她说她无法理解为什么有人会自愿去战区，冒着生命危险去帮助那些我们并不真正在乎的人。这话说得很刻薄，但这就是她说的。
Well, let me ask you, what's the answer to your wife's question? Why go to Iraq?
好吧，让我问你，你妻子问题的答案是什么？为什么要来伊拉克？
I just couldn't stand watching it on TV anymore from the sidelines. I come from my father, mother, brother, uncle, we're all Marines. And you think to yourself, is there something that I could contribute in a positive way?
我只是无法再站在边线上看电视了。我来自一个军人家庭，父亲、母亲、兄弟、叔叔，我们全家都是海军陆战队。你会想，我能以某种积极的方式做出贡献吗？
Now, if this sounds old-fashioned or grand, I should tell you that Randy Frescoln is more qualified to contribute in a positive way to the reconstruction of Iraq than most of us. In 2004, he did that same job in Afghanistan, setting up orchards and bridges and water systems and vocational training and all kinds of other stuff. Which actually is not too different from the job he does here in the States. He works for the US Department of Agriculture in Iowa, where he has set up hundreds of projects to help communities and businesses all over the state. He's the kind of guy who loves driving down the highway and spotting a biodiesel plant or wind turbines that he helped fund.
现在，如果这听起来老派或宏大，我得告诉你，兰迪·弗雷斯科伦比我们大多数人更有资格以积极的方式为伊拉克重建做出贡献。2004年，他在阿富汗做过同样的工作，建立果园、桥梁、供水系统、职业培训和各种其他东西。这实际上和他在这里在美国做的工作没什么不同。他为美国农业部在爱荷华州工作，在那里他建立了数百个项目来帮助全州各地的社区和企业。他就是那种喜欢开车在高速公路上，看到他帮助资助的生物柴油厂或风力涡轮机就会感到自豪的人。
But what happened to him in Iraq changed him, made him rethink what it means to help people, to serve your country, to do good. He got there in December, 2006, lived on an army base in the Sunni triangle. And it was so violent that any time he left the base to meet with Iraqis, he had a full military escort and was told that convoys carrying his co-workers had been hit eight times.
但他在伊拉克的经历改变了他，让他重新思考帮助他人、为国效力、做好事意味着什么。他于2006年12月到达那里，住在逊尼派三角区的一个陆军基地里。那里太暴力了，他每次离开基地与伊拉克人会面，都有完整的军事护送，而且被告知载着他同事的车队已经遭到八次袭击。
But the biggest difference from his experience in Afghanistan was the people. Any Iraqis who talked to him risked being seen as collaborators and killed. So he didn't get close to anybody. After one meeting with local agricultural leaders, Randy's translator took him aside and told him that the Iraqis had been saying to each other, during the meeting in Arabic, just tell the Americans whatever they want to hear. Nobody seemed to see him as anything but somebody to be appeased, or somebody to demand things from, a nuisance, or the enemy.
但他与阿富汗经历最大的不同是人。任何与他交谈的伊拉克人都冒着被视为勾结者并被杀害的风险。所以他没能和任何人亲近。在与当地农业领导人举行了一次会议后，兰迪的翻译把他拉到一边，告诉他，伊拉克人在会议期间用阿拉伯语对彼此说：“别管那么多，只要告诉美国人他们想听的话就行了。”似乎没人把他看作什么，除了一个可以安抚的人，或者是可以从中索要东西的人，一个累赘，或者敌人。
Is there some that you thought would kill you if they had the opportunity? Yeah. I had never encountered-- what you could say the word-- hatred than I got from some of those folks over there. It was the worst feeling in my life. You go, what a dumbass I am for jeopardizing my career, my family, to come all the way over here for this. How dumb are you?
有没有那么一刻你觉得他们如果有机会就会杀了你？有。我从来没遇到过——怎么说呢——那种仇恨，我从那些人身上感受到了。那是我一生中最糟糕的感觉。你会想，我真是个笨蛋，为了来这里冒着牺牲事业、牺牲家庭的风险，来这儿受这个罪。你有多蠢啊？
Tell me about a time when you felt that. Tell me about a time when that actually happened to you. Who were you talking to?
告诉我你感受到那一刻的事情。告诉我那件事真正发生在你身上的时候。你在和谁谈话？
Probably the University, because I had very high expectations for the University. You would think they're good people doing good things. Well, when I get there, they brought in two professors who got their PhDs in America.
可能是大学，因为我对大学抱有非常高的期望。你会认为他们是做善事的好人。好吧，当我到那儿时，他们带进来了两位在美获得博士学位的教授。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
And one of them had worked for USDA for three years in Wyoming.
其中一个人曾在怀俄明州的美国农业部工作过三年。
So you just felt like, OK, that's it. I'm set. We're good.
所以你只是觉得，好了，就是这样。我搞定了。我们挺好的。
Yeah, I looked at him and I said, you know exactly what I'm here for, what we're trying to do. And they said, yes. And then we carried on our dialogue. And I kept looking at him. And  I finally said, I see something in your eyes. What is it that I don't know that you need to tell me. And I had to ask him that multiple times. And finally, they said, you need to understand. He's in charge.
是的，我看着他，我说，你知道我为什么来，我们想做什么。他们说，是的。然后我们继续对话。但我一直盯着他看。我终于说，我在你眼里看到了一些东西。我不知道你需要告诉我什么？我不得不问了他好几次。最后，他们说，你得明白，他才是负责任的。
And he was their boss. It started to dawn on Randy that even here, even in the University, with these two Iraqis who actually seemed to understand him, even here he was not going to get anywhere. Instead of the normal things that farmers might need in a poor or economically-ravaged country, their boss asked for high-tech equipment.
而他是他们的上司。兰迪开始意识到，即使在这里，即使在大学，和这两个看起来似乎理解他的伊拉克人在一起，他在这里也不会有任何进展。他们没有要求贫穷或遭受经济破坏的国家农民通常需要的正常东西，他们的上司反而要求提供高科技设备。
If you're trying to build capacity, if you don't have anything, the last thing you're going to ask for is advanced technology like that, right? Why would you want that? So it could be sold for cash.
如果你想建立能力，如果你一无所有，你最后要索要的肯定是那种先进技术，对吧？你为什么要那个？为了卖掉换现金。
Oh, I see.
哦，我明白了。
Yeah.
是的。
Despite all this, Randy was able to accomplish a couple things. He set up a model program that got Iraqi farmers and tribal Sheiks and the University and the government working together for the first time. But he and other people in these civilian jobs in Iraq wonder sometimes, is that level of success worth it?
尽管如此，兰迪还是取得了一些成就。他建立了一个示范项目，让伊拉克农民、部落酋长、大学和政府第一次共同努力。但他和这些在伊拉克担任文职工作的人有时会怀疑，这种程度的成功值得吗？
Randy and other civilians are sent through Iraq on what are officially called PRTs, Provincial Reconstruction Teams. These were established two and a half years after the US invasion, with the idea that they were going to create small economic development projects. And also they were going to train local governments around Iraq to do the things that local governments do in a democracy: devise budgets, hold meetings in front of the public, set up courthouses with local judges.
兰迪和其他文职人员被派往伊拉克执行正式称为“省级重建小组”（PRTs）的任务。这些小组是在美国入侵两年半后建立的，初衷是创建小型经济发展项目。他们还打算培训伊拉克各地的当地政府，去做民主国家地方政府做的事情：制定预算、在公众面前举行会议、建立当地法官的法院。
But from the start, the PRTs have been plagued by a lack of planning, qualified people, money. Civilians found themselves in war zones without telephones to do their jobs, or desks. An article in the in-house magazine for State Department employees, the Foreign Service Journal , said, quote, "a common refrain from foreign service members speaking about their experience in new PRTs is that they have felt like pins on a map, sent out so officials in Washington could say they were there. They felt cut off and were given no clear instruction on their role."
但从一开始，省级重建小组就受到缺乏规划、缺乏合格人员和资金的困扰。文职人员发现自己身处战区，却没有电话来工作，甚至没有办公桌。国务院内部杂志《外交服务杂志》的一篇文章说，引用，“外国服务人员在谈到他们在新PRT的经历时，常说他们感觉就像地图上的大头针，被派出去只是为了让华盛顿的官员可以说他们在那里。他们感到被切断了联系，也没有被明确告知他们的职责。”
I was retired at the time. And I have to say that I was against the invasion from the very beginning. Nevertheless, we did it. And this is my country. So when a call went out for people with the kind of background I had, I thought it was perhaps a moral obligation to go and see if I could do something useful.
我当时退休了。我不得不说，我从一开始就反对入侵。尽管如此，我们还是做了。而这是我的国家。所以当有人呼吁背景和我一样的人时，我想也许去看看我是否能做点有用的事是一种道德义务。
Kiki Munshi is a veteran diplomat who ran the PRT in Diyala province, and is now back in the United States. In testimony to Congress this February, she said that in spite of the quote, "quietly heroic work of lots of people, the PRTs cannot succeed. The obstacles are too great."
基基·蒙希（Kiki Munshi）是一位老练的外交官，曾领导迪亚拉省的PRT，现在回到了美国。在今年二月的国会证词中，她说，尽管有引用，“许多人默默的英勇工作，但PRT无法成功。障碍太大了。”
The biggest problem is the obvious one, the violence. She says you can't create local democracy without the rule of law. In Diyala province, she was working with the provincial council, which is the local government. She was feeling optimistic. And then everything really fell apart when a Shiite general was assigned to run the Iraqi army in that particular area.
最大的问题显而易见，就是暴力。她说，没有法治就无法建立地方民主。在迪亚拉省，她正在与省议会合作，那是当地政府。她当时感到乐观。然后，当一名什叶派将军被指派在该地区领导伊拉克军队时，一切都彻底崩溃了。
--who at first seemed like a very good person. But gradually we began to see warning signs. He was transferring Sunni officers out, replacing them with Shia. And our military compiled a very complete dossier on the fact that he was running death squads against the Sunni, doing mass detentions, torture, a lot of unpleasant things that would not promote intersecterian peace.
……起初看起来像个非常好的人。但渐渐地我们开始看到危险信号。他把逊尼派官员调离，取而代之以什叶派。我们的军方整理了一份非常完整的档案，证明他正在针对逊尼派执行“死亡小队”任务，进行大规模拘留、酷刑，以及许多不促进宗派间和平的不愉快事情。
And so did that pretty much mean the end of all your projects?
所以那基本上意味着你所有项目的终结？
Yes. Yes, gradually the provincial council stopped meeting. They haven't had a quorum since October. The business then left. The ones who could afford it went on to Syria or to Jordan. The ones who couldn't have gone to Baghdad.
是的。是的，渐渐地省议会停止了开会。自十月以来，他们就再也没有法定人数了。企业随后离开了。负担得起的人去了叙利亚或约旦。负担不起的人去了巴格达。
The security situation around the PRTs is so tough that an audit by the Special Inspector General for Iraq Reconstruction found that only four of 13 PRTs were generally able to carry out their missions, and recommended closing offices in two provinces.
PRT周边的安全局势极其严峻，美国伊拉克重建特别监察长的审计发现，13个PRT中只有4个总体上能够执行其使命，并建议关闭两个省的办事处。
Few people are faced with the decision is it worth dying for? That's the Iraqi question.
很少有人面临“是否值得为之献身”的决定。这就是伊拉克问题。
The question of whether PRTs are actually worth anybody's life became a very personal question for Randy Frescoln. Just three months into his one-year stint in Iraq, he decided to quit. I cannot say strongly enough how this shook him up.
PRT是否真正值得任何人生命的问题，对兰迪·弗雷斯科伦来说变成了一个非常个人的问题。在他一年期伊拉克任务刚进行三个月时，他决定辞职。我怎么强调这种事对他打击之大都不为过。
You know what? Even today, it still bothers me that-- even today, I go, I know I went for the right reasons. I feel incredibly good, what I accomplished. It still eats at my gut.
你知道吗？即使在今天，这仍然困扰着我……即使在今天，我也会想，我知道我是为了正确的理由去的。我感觉非常好，我完成了什么。它仍然折磨着我的内心。
And talk about how you made that decision.
谈谈你是如何做出那个决定的。
Well, every three months, they schedule R&Rs. You're supposed to have rest and relaxation. And for me is, when I started working on that, I called home, and I was talking about dates and that sort of thing. And my little nine-year-old girl asked me very honestly, very simply, when she found out I was going back, that I was coming home and not staying, she said, why are you going to go back to Iraq?
嗯，他们每三个月安排一次休假（R&R）。你应该有休息和放松。对我来说，当开始处理那个问题时，我给家里打电话，我谈论日期之类的。我的九岁小女儿非常诚实、非常简单地问我，当她发现我要回伊拉克时，我正要回家而不是留下，她说：“你为什么要回伊拉克？”
And for two nights, I couldn't sleep thinking about that. And it's a tough question, because it's still going through my mind. I'm still going through my mind, trying to come up with answers. But for me, the cost exceeded the benefit. And I don't know-- for me, it's not worth dying for the people that I was working with. I don't know how else to explain it. If I would have died trying to help them, none of them would have cared. And the only one that would have bore the price was my family.
那天晚上我有两个晚上没法睡觉，在想那个问题。这是一个很难的问题，因为它仍然在我脑海里挥之不去。我仍然在脑海中盘旋，试图想出答案。但对我来说，代价超过了利益。我不知道……对我来说，为了我一起工作的人而死是不值得的。我不知道该如何解释。如果我死在帮助他们的过程中，他们中的任何人都不会在乎。唯一承受代价的人就是我的家人。
He had gone to Iraq saying he wanted to do his part in the war on terror. And he came back telling his 18-year-old son not to sign up.
他去伊拉克时说他想在反恐战争中尽一份力。而他回来时告诉他18岁的儿子不要报名。
That's what I told him. He had both Air Force and a Navy college scholarships that he was working on. And I said, son, when Paris Hilton can get drafted, and George Bush's daughters get drafted, when everybody can get drafted and serve, and they declare war, then I'll want you in the military.
这就是我告诉他的。他当时有空军和海军的大学奖学金，他正在努力争取。我说，儿子，当帕丽斯·希尔顿（Paris Hilton）能被征召入伍，乔治·布什（George Bush）的女儿们能被征召入伍，当所有人都能被征召入伍并服役，且他们宣布战争时，我才会希望你参军。
And what did your son say?
你儿子说了什么？
He listened. Because before I had left for Iraq, anybody who raised an opposition to the war I thought was extremely unpatriotic. Like I said, I'm about as red, white, and blue of a guy as you could possibly want, and from a military family. But I guess we need to talk in a rational manner about what's the cost benefits of us getting involved in the world.
他听进去了。因为在我去伊拉克之前，任何提出反对战争的人我都认为是极其不爱国的。就像我说的，我是一个尽可能爱国的人，来自军人家庭。但我猜我们需要以理性的方式讨论我们在世界上参与的成本收益是什么。
I, as a team leader, and my deputy team leader had to make the decision, was this mission today worth risking not just the lives of our people that work directly for us, but the lives of the soldiers that were going to be sent out in the convoy to protect them?
我作为团队领导，和我的副团队领导，必须做出决定：今天的这个任务是否值得冒风险，不仅是我们直接雇员的生命，还有将被派往车队保护他们的士兵的生命？
Stephanie Miley was Randy's boss in Iraq. She set up the PRT in Tikrit. And she ran it while Randy was there. And so it's the second assignment that she volunteered for in Iraq. And when she looks at the costs and benefits of having the PRTs, she points to successes. Her PRT got the provincial council to have open meetings with the press there, and budgets that anybody can look up. They trained policemen to get proper evidence and started planning an economic development zone.
斯蒂芬妮·麦利（Stephanie Miley）是兰迪在伊拉克的上司。她在提克里特建立了PRT。兰迪在那里时她负责管理。这是她第二次自愿参加伊拉克任务。当她审视PRT的成本和收益时，她指出了成功。她的PRT让省议会与当地媒体举行公开会议，制定了任何人都可以查询的预算。他们培训警察获取适当的证据，并开始规划经济开发区。
I asked her about the things that Randy said made him decide that it wasn't worth it to stay in Iraq-- that it was too hard to do much good for people. Maybe it's just too soon to do economic and political development, if any Iraqi who meets with Americans becomes a target for assassination.
我问她兰迪所说的让他决定不值得留在伊拉克的理由——因为很难为人们做好事。也许现在进行经济和政治发展还为时过早，因为任何与美国人会面的伊拉克人都可能成为暗杀目标。
Well, we did talk at the time. And I want to say Randy made some excellent contributions to our work there. And I think the things that he put in place, we're still seeing progress on that. Not the progress we would like, but progress. I think there are a couple things to consider when we're thinking about this. Certainly the contractors who work on projects are targeted and killed, the workers intimidated, and things like that.
嗯，我们当时确实谈过。我想说，兰迪对我们的工作做出了一些卓越的贡献。我认为他实施的事情，我们仍在看到进展。不是我们想要的进展，但确实有进展。我认为我们在考虑这个问题时有几件事要考量。当然，从事项目的承包商遭到针对和杀害，工人们受到恐吓，诸如此类。
It's a very difficult emotional issue, frankly. Because when I first arrived in the country, I met the governor of the province, Ala'Adeen. And he said to me, you know, I want you to meet my wife. Because you two are just alike. You're professional women trying to make Iraq better. And I did have the opportunity to meet his wife several times. She was the head surgeon for the maternity ward at the teaching hospital in Tikrit, a lovely woman.
坦率地说，这是一个非常困难的情感问题。因为当我刚到这个国家时，我见到了省长阿拉丁（Ala'Adeen）。他对我说，你知道，我希望你见见我的妻子。因为你们两个太像了。你们都是专业的女性，试图让伊拉克变得更好。我确实有机会几次见到他的妻子。她是提克里特教学医院妇产科的首席外科医生，一位可爱的女性。
Governor was very proud of his wife and what she was doing and things like that. And I asked her how it was that she had met the governor, because he was a few years older than she. And she explained that her sister, who was also a physician-- they had gone to school together, lived together, practiced together-- had been kidnapped two years before. The governor had assisted the family, trying to find out what had happened. They thought it was a ransom issue. It turned out to be that she'd been kidnapped by terrorists and was executed. So that is how she met the governor.
省长为他的妻子和她正在做的事情感到非常骄傲。我问她是怎么认识省长的，因为他比她大几岁。她解释说，她的妹妹也是一名医生——她们一起上学、住在一起、一起实习——两年前被绑架了。省长曾协助这家人，试图查明发生了什么。他们以为是勒索问题。结果发现是被恐怖分子绑架并处决了。所以她就是这样认识省长的。
We met, as I said, several times. And one thing that she really wanted me to do was to work with her on what was going on at the hospital. And so on July 10, I had the opportunity last year to go to the teaching hospital, meet with her and several others, take a tour, see the facilities, see what their needs were to work on it. On July 11, she walked into her clinic and was blown up by an IED. They were waiting for her.
正如我所说，我们见过好几次。她真心希望我做的一件事是和我一起处理医院正在发生的事情。所以去年7月10日，我有机会去教学医院，和她及其他人会面，参观，查看设施，看看他们的需求是什么。7月11日，她走进诊所时被简易爆炸装置炸死了。他们一直在等她。
It's very difficult to see something like that happen to a person who is the future of Iraq. It's very difficult to see that happen to the governor, who was understandably devastated by the loss of his wife. And it's very difficult to think that maybe because she was seen as being too close to the US presence there, that she became more of a target. It can sometimes be a very difficult position to be in, as Randy was saying, when you realize that the people you're talking to today may not be there tomorrow because they were talking to you today.
眼睁睁看着这种事发生在伊拉克的未来身上，非常艰难。看到这种事发生在省长身上，非常艰难，他理所当然地被妻子的去世所摧毁。想到也许正因为她被视为与那里的美国存在走得太近，才成为目标，这非常艰难。就像兰迪所说，当你意识到你今天与之交谈的人明天可能就不在了，因为他们今天与你交谈了，有时候这会是一个非常困难的处境。
Well, here's the thing I really wanted to talk to you about, is I've talked to people who have been at PRTs. And the conclusion that they've come to is that it's too soon for these to be effective, or they don't feel like they're doing enough good to justify being there themselves. And it seems like you've come to a different conclusion, that actually it's worth doing the PRTs, and it's worth trying to make this stuff happen now. And I wonder, why? Could you talk about that?
嗯，我真的想和你谈的是，我和那些在PRT工作过的人谈过。他们得出的结论是，现在让这些项目生效还为时过早，或者他们不觉得自己在那里做的好事足以证明在那里的价值。你似乎得出了不同的结论，即PRT确实值得做，现在尝试做这些事情是值得的。我想知道，为什么？你能谈谈吗？
Sure. I think it's worth doing because it is showing the Iraqi people that we are there with them in partnership. We are not abandoning them. So it's going to go in fits and starts. Some of these things happen in a strange fashion, where there's a long lag time. And then suddenly the dam breaks and things move forward.
当然。我认为值得做，因为它向伊拉克人民展示了我们与他们是伙伴关系。我们没有抛弃他们。所以它会是断断续续的。其中一些事情以奇怪的方式发生，长时间的滞后。然后突然堤坝决口，事情向前推进。
So it's a difficult thing. I do believe that PRTs are the way forward, because I don't see the alternative. We can't have a situation where the US military is the only presence. But you just have to push forward on all of these areas at the same time.
所以这是一件困难的事情。我确实相信PRT是未来的方向，因为我看不到替代方案。我们不能让美军成为唯一存在的情况。但你必须同时在所有这些领域向前推进。
In January, President Bush proposed doubling the number of PRTs this year. And those plans are being put into effect. Currently available PRT jobs in Iraq are listed at federalgovernmentjobs.us among other sites. Coming up, strangers in the night exchanging glances-- will one of them murder the other? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
一月份，布什总统提议今年将PRT数量增加一倍。这些计划正在实施。目前伊拉克的PRT空缺职位列在federalgovernmentjobs.us以及其他网站上。接下来，夜里的陌生人交换了眼神——他们中的一个人会谋杀另一个吗？那是芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台节目继续后的内容。
[MUSIC - "SKAVAVARS" BY BENNI HEMM HEMM]
[音乐 - 贝尼·亨姆·亨姆（Benni Hemm Hemm）的《SKAVAVARS》]
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. This week on our show, Who Can You Save? And we've arrived at act three of our show. Act Three, The Murderer. Well, so far, we've heard today about people deciding whether they would save babies, whether they would save people from a train, whether they would save Iraq. Brady Udall has this story about people facing a few other decisions like this.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。本周在我们的节目中，你能拯救谁？我们已经进入节目的第三幕。第三幕，谋杀者。嗯，到目前为止，我们今天已经听到了人们决定是否要拯救婴儿，是否要从火车下拯救人们，是否要拯救伊拉克。布雷迪·尤达尔（Brady Udall）讲述了这个关于人们面临其他类似决策的故事。
The deepest hours of a wintry Iowa night, and it sounded like somebody was knocking on our sliding glass door. I had been typing on the computer down in our basement, and I told myself that the sound had to be a raccoon or a stray dog sniffing around on the deck. Or maybe it was my wife, who was supposed to be sleeping in the bedroom with our newborn son, up to get a glass of water. But then it came again, the hollow sound of a knuckle rapping on glass.
在一个寒冷的爱荷华冬夜，深更半夜，听起来像是有人在敲我们的滑动玻璃门。我当时在地下室的电脑上打字，我告诉自己那声音一定是一只浣熊或一只流浪狗在露台上乱嗅。又或者是我的妻子，她应该和我们刚出生的儿子在卧室睡觉，起来去喝水。但随后声音又来了，指关节敲击玻璃发出的沉闷声音。
Had we still lived in town, a visitor dropping by at 3:00 AM wouldn't have been such a surprise. In Iowa City, it wasn't all that uncommon to have a half-drunk sorority girl pop in to ask if we had any spare condoms, of for one of my fellow graduate students to come by to recite his latest confessional poem, usually titled something like "Why I Bleed." But six months ago, we had said goodbye to the cosmopolitan nightlife of Iowa City and moved out to this remote cabin on the banks of the Iowa River in an effort to simplify our lives, to get closer to the natural world, and most importantly, to discourage people from dropping by to read their poetry to us. Our nearest neighbor was a quarter of a mile away on the opposite side of the river.
如果我们还住在城里，半夜3点有人来访也就不足为奇了。在爱荷华城，半醉的大学女生跑来问我们有没有多余的避孕套，或者我的研究生同学来朗诵他最新的忏悔诗，通常标题叫什么“我为何流血”，这并不罕见。但六个月前，我们告别了爱荷华城繁华的夜生活，搬到了爱荷华河畔这个遥远的小屋，试图简化我们的生活，更接近自然世界，最重要的是，为了不让人们再跑来给我们读诗。离我们最近的邻居在河对岸，四分之一英里外。
I walked up the stairs, comforting myself with the idea that homicidal maniacs aren't generally known for having the courtesy to knock before entering the houses of their victims. I got to the top and saw who was waiting outside. On the other side of the glass was a man who bore a strong resemblance to the murderer I had been imagining. Six foot four, greasy black hair, a misaligned face pocked with acne scars. I could tell right away that this was not a person who had been blessed with a happy childhood. His clothes: long overcoat, combat boots, Judas Priest concert t-shirt were crusted with mud. And it appeared that he had spent the entire evening digging graves and now only needed the bodies to fill them with.
我走上楼梯，安慰自己说凶手通常不会有礼貌地在进入受害者屋子前敲门。我走到楼顶，看见外面等着的人。玻璃的另一边是一个男人，长得和我想象中的杀人犯很像。6英尺4英寸，油腻的黑发，凹凸不平的脸上满是痘痕。我一眼就能看出这不是一个童年幸福的人。他的衣服：长外套、作战靴、犹大圣徒乐队（Judas Priest）演唱会T恤上沾满了泥土。看起来他好像整晚都在挖坟，现在只差尸体去填了。
We looked at each other for a good long time, this man and I. Because I had been laboring all night in the freezing basement, I happened to be wearing my wife's magenta flannel-lined jogging outfit, metallic running shoes, and a novelty ski hat that looked like something you might find on the head of an elf. We were both, it was clear, deeply troubled by the sight of each other.
我们看着对方看了好长一段时间，这个男人和我。因为我在冰冷的地下室忙了一整晚，我碰巧穿着妻子的洋红色法兰绒内衬慢跑服，金属感运动鞋，还有一个看起来像精灵戴的那种新奇滑雪帽。很明显，我们都被对方的样子深深困扰了。
It's difficult to explain why I didn't do something sensible, like go for the knife drawer, or barricade myself in the bedroom and call 911. I believe it had to do with my weakened state at the time. I was in what my mother would have generously called "a funk." There had been complications with the birth of our son, which our meager insurance had failed to cover, and we were now sunk in debt. I was spent, sorry for myself, and apparently didn't have the energy or the guts to defend my home and family. So when the murderer knocked again on the glass, I slid the door open, and like somebody manning the drive-thru at Wendy's asked, "may I help you?"
很难解释为什么我没做点明智的事情，比如去拿刀架里的刀，或者把自己关在卧室里拨打911。我相信这和我当时虚弱的状态有关。我处于母亲会大度地称之为“忧郁”的状态。我们儿子的出生出现了一些并发症，我们微薄的保险没能覆盖，我们现在负债累累。我筋疲力尽，为自己感到难过，显然没有精力和胆量去保卫我的家和家人。所以当杀人犯再次敲玻璃时，我滑开门，像在温蒂汉堡窗口服务的员工一样问道：“有什么能帮您的吗？”
The first thing he said to me was, "man, take a look at my hand." He held up his hand and I could see that his knuckles were shredded and bleeding. It looked like he'd tried to cram his fist into a blender. "I ran my car off the road," he said. "And I got so mad, I punched a tree, which I now regret."
他对我说第一句话是：“伙计，看看我的手。”他举起手，我看到他的指关节被擦破了，血流如注。看起来像是他试图把拳头塞进搅拌机里。他说：“我把车开下了路。我太生气了，所以打了一棵树，现在很后悔。”
I had no response to that, so I did the only thing I could think of, which was to invite him in. "Oh, I wouldn't want to track mud on your carpet," said the murderer. He explained that his car was stuck, and he needed some help getting it out. He made it clear that he wanted to do this without the cops or any other public authorities getting involved, and wondered if I could give him a hand.
对此我没法回应，所以我做了唯一能想到的事，那就是请他进来。“哦，我不想在你的地毯上弄上泥土，”杀人犯说。他解释说他的车卡住了，需要一些帮助弄出来。他明确表示，他想在没有警察或其他公共当局介入的情况下处理这件事，想知道我是否能帮把手。
"Man," he said, "I'm partying with this guy Peanut. Maybe you've heard of him. And then I'm driving home, minding my own [BLEEP] business, and the next thing I know, my car is sunk up to the axles in a dry lakebed. What the [BLEEP], right? It's on the other side of those trees there. Not far at all. I'll do all the pushing. All you've got to do is work the controls."
“伙计，”他说，“我和那个叫花生（Peanut）的家伙聚会。也许你听说过他。然后我开车回家，处理我自己的[哔——]事，下一件事我就知道，我的车在干涸的湖床上陷到车轴了。搞什么[哔——]，对吧？就在那些树的另一边。一点也不远。我会完成所有推车的活。你只需要操作控制装置就行了。”
I told him I would get my coat and shoes and be right with him. I slipped into the bathroom, suddenly weak with relief. I felt I had been spared, at least for the moment, and it felt very, very good. But this guy's story about his car being stuck in a lakebed seemed suspicious. Surely it was a ruse to lure me into the woods so he and his friend Peanut could take care of me with the least amount of fuss, and then later return to plunder my house and butcher my family.
我告诉他我会拿上外套和鞋子，马上就来。我溜进浴室，突然因解脱而感到虚弱。我觉得我至少暂时得救了，感觉非常好。但这家伙关于车困在湖床上的故事似乎很可疑。肯定是个诡计，想把我引诱到树林里，这样他和他的朋友花生就能用最简单的方式解决我，然后再回来洗劫我的房子，屠杀我的家人。
My survival instincts, which had been in remission for a few months now, began to stir. I decided I needed something to defend myself with. There were the knives in the kitchen, but they were in plain view of the deck. And my chainsaw, which I used as a makeshift weed whacker to keep the thistles down around the house, was out in the shed. For some time, I considered the plunger next to the toilet.
我的生存本能，几个月来一直处于缓解状态，开始苏醒。我决定需要点东西来保护自己。厨房里有刀，但从露台上能一览无余。我的链锯，我曾用它当作临时割草机来清除屋子周围的蓟草，在棚子里。好一阵子，我考虑了厕所旁边的马桶吸盘。
I ransacked the bathroom. And in a cabinet under the sink, I found a hammer my wife had once used to build bird houses. It was tiny, almost a toy, and I don't think you could've broken open a soft-boiled egg with that hammer. But unlike the plunger, I could hide it safely in the band of my wife's jogging pants. And in the event that I had to defend myself with it, at least I would be able to leave this world with a small scrap of dignity.
我翻遍了浴室。在水槽下的柜子里，我发现了一把妻子曾经用来搭建鸟屋的锤子。它很小，简直像个玩具，我不认为你能用那把锤子打破一个软煮蛋。但不同于吸盘，我可以把它安全地藏在妻子的慢跑裤裤腰里。如果我必须用它保护自己，至少我能带着一点点尊严离开这个世界。
Once I had the hammer tucked safely away, I met the murderer out on the deck. And without further ado, he led me into the dark forest. I hadn't thought to bring a flashlight. And once we had moved away from the house, it was utterly black. I tripped over stumps, and saplings stabbed me in the eyes with their branches. He made comments like, "just past this gulley, I think," and "not too much longer," and "ow, [BLEEP], what was that," and "oh, [BLEEP] log."
一旦我把锤子藏好，我就在露台上见到了那个杀人犯。没有更多的废话，他带我进入了黑暗的森林。我没带手电筒。一旦离开房子，外面就彻底黑了。我被树桩绊倒，树苗的树枝刺进我的眼睛。他发表评论说：“就在这个沟渠过去，我想，”和“没多久了”，和“哎哟，[哔——]，那是什么”，和“哦，[哔——]原木”。
After a while, I couldn't hear him anymore, and I thought I'd lost him completely. But then he was behind me, his boots crunching on the frost-crusted leaves. Now that my eyes had adjusted to the darkness, I thought I could see the dark form of Peanut or some other delinquent crouching behind every other thicket or tree. I felt the hair on my arms stand up. And it came to me with a certainty. This was it. The ambush was on. I was going to die in these lonely, barren woods, wearing a woman's jogging suit and the hat of an elf.
过了一会儿，我再也听不到他的声音了，我以为彻底跟丢了他。但随后他在我身后，靴子在结霜的叶子上发出嘎吱声。现在我的眼睛已经适应了黑暗，我觉得我能看到每一个灌木丛或树后面都蹲着黑影，花生或其他犯罪分子。我感到胳膊上的毛发竖了起来。我确信无疑。就是这个了。埋伏开始了。我要死在这些孤独、荒凉的树林里，穿着女人的慢跑服和精灵的帽子。
It was around this time that the hammer slipped out of my waist band and made its way down the leg of my pants. In a panic, I hopped on one foot. And as casually as possible, tried to shake the hammer out of the cuff of my pants so it would fall unnoticed to the side of the path. I thought I might have succeeded until I heard the footfalls stop behind me. "Dropped your hammer," the murderer said.
大约在这个时候，锤子从我的腰带里溜出来，掉进了我的裤腿里。惊慌失措中，我用一只脚跳着走。并尽可能自然地试图把锤子从裤脚里摇出来，这样它就能在不被注意的情况下掉在小路旁边。我以为我成功了，直到我听到身后的脚步声停止了。“掉了你的锤子，”杀人犯说。
"Oh, yes. Thank you," I said, and immediately began swatting at thickets and overhanging branches as if I had brought it along for the purpose of clearing out brush. I hacked at every bramble and dead weed in reach until we emerged from the trees. There, not 50 feet in front of us, sat a generously dented duster sunk in the mud of a barren cornfield. The murderer slapped me on the back. "God damn," he said. "You found it."
“哦，是的。谢谢，”我说，并立即开始猛拍灌木丛和悬垂的树枝，好像我是为了清理杂草而带着它一样。我狂砍伸手可及的每一丛荆棘和枯草，直到我们走出树林。在那里，离我们不到50英尺远，坐着一辆车身凹陷的除尘者，陷在荒凉玉米地的泥里。杀人犯拍了拍我的背。“该死的，”他说。“你找到了。”
There is not much to say about the fiasco that followed. We were able to push the car out of one rut only to get it stuck in another. We'd get it moving across the furrows, wheels spinning and mud flying everywhere, our hopes on the rise, only to watch it lose traction and sink slowly back into the muck. More than once, my companion tried to give up. But I was a constant source of encouragement. I had all the energy in the world. While he sat up front, pressing wearily on the gas, I labored at the back bumper in a hailstorm of mud.
关于接下来的闹剧没什么好说的。我们好不容易把车从一个车辙推出来，却又陷进了另一个。我们让它穿过犁沟，车轮打转，泥浆四处飞溅，我们的希望燃起，却又眼睁睁看着它失去抓地力，慢慢陷回淤泥里。不止一次，我的同伴想放弃。但我一直是鼓励的源泉。我有用不完的能量。当他坐在前面，疲惫地踩着油门时，我在泥浆中奋力推着后保险杠。
After nearly an hour, we were both so surprised at having got it up on the gravel road that we nearly let it roll into the ditch on the other side. Wearied and encased entirely in mud, we slumped against the car to get our wind back. The murderer heaved and clutched his side. "Son of a bitch," he said, "I think I activated my hernia again."
近一小时后，我们俩都对能把它弄到碎石路上感到如此惊讶，几乎让它滚进另一边的沟里。精疲力竭且满身泥浆，我们瘫在车旁恢复气息。杀人犯气喘吁吁地捂着侧身。“狗娘养的，”他说，“我想我的疝气又犯了。”
He eventually climbed into his car and in the rubbish pile on the passenger side floor located a pen and scrap of paper. With great care and concentration, he wrote something on the paper and handed it to me. In stylish, looping cursive, it said, "Donny Solomon, 377-2908, Malibu Acres Trailer Park."
他最终爬进车里，在副驾驶地板的垃圾堆里找到了一支笔和一张纸。他非常小心且专注地在纸上写了些什么，递给我。上面用时髦、连贯的草书写着：“唐尼·所罗门（Donny Solomon），377-2908，马里布山庄拖车公园。”
"That's my name and privileged information," he said. "Very few people have access to it. You need something, you just call that number or head over to Malibu Acres and say my name. They'll know where to find me. He stood up and regarded me intently. "I mean anything. I don't care where or what it is, which side of the law it's on. You've done me a great favor here tonight."
“这是我的名字和保密信息，”他说。“很少有人能得到它。你需要什么，就打那个电话或直接去马里布山庄报我的名字。他们会知道在哪儿找到我。”他站起来，凝视着我。“我是说任何事。我不关心在哪儿或是什么事，无论在法律的哪一边。你今晚帮了我大忙。”
I took off my elf hat, wiped my forehead, and patted the hood of the duster. "Just glad I could be of help," I said. Before he got back in his car, he pulled me in and hooked his arm around my shoulder in a manly half-hug. "Hey," he said in a little voice, "maybe you're queer or whatever. But that don't mean nothing to me." He drove off, sliding all over the frosty road, and I trudged home, making sure to lock the door behind me.
我摘下精灵帽，擦了擦额头，拍了拍除尘车的引擎盖。“很高兴能帮上忙，”我说。在他回到车里之前，他把我拉过去，胳膊勾住我的肩膀，给我一个男人的半拥抱。“嘿，”他轻声说，“也许你是同性恋还是别的。但对我来说无所谓。”他开车离去，在结霜的路上滑来滑去，我拖着脚步回家，确保锁好身后的门。
This is a story I used to tell all the time. I'm partial to it because, unlike most of the stories I tell, it's almost entirely true. And as stories go, it's a good one. A dark and stormy night, a stranger at the door, a little comic relief to lighten the mood, and that which brightens every heart, a happy ending. Even better, it had provided me with a prop, that mud-smeared scrap of paper with Donny Solomon's name and privileged information.
这是一个我过去常讲的故事。我偏爱它，因为不像我讲的大多数故事，它几乎完全是真的。作为故事，它很棒。一个黑暗而风暴的夜晚，门外的陌生人，一点喜剧色彩来缓和气氛，还有那让每个心灵振奋的东西——一个快乐的结局。更好的是，它给了我一个道具，那张涂满泥浆的写着唐尼·所罗门名字和保密信息的纸。
After that night in Iowa, I didn't see Donny Solomon for six years, had no communication at all with him. But that didn't prevent him from becoming a part of my life. I had told the story so often, invoked his name so many times, that I began to think of him as a friend. There were times during those six years that I came close to calling in the favor he'd promised. There are so many people in our lives who might benefit from a sound beating at the hands of an ex-con. But I kept his phone number folded in my wallet for the day when I truly needed it. Just the idea of that slip of paper was a comfort. I did not need God or the saints or any other higher power. I had Donny Solomon.
在那晚爱荷华之后，我有六年没见过唐尼·所罗门，没有任何联系。但这并没有阻止他成为我生活的一部分。我讲这个故事讲得太频繁，引述他的名字太多次，以至于我开始把他当作一个朋友。在这六年中，有几次我差点就打了电话去行使他承诺给我的那个人情。在我们生活中，有太多人可能会从前科犯的一顿痛揍中受益。但我把他的电话号码折叠在钱包里，留到我真正需要的那一天。单是这张纸条的想法就是一种安慰。我不需要上帝、圣徒或其他任何更高级的力量。我有唐尼·所罗门。
And then, in the summer of 2002, I found myself back in Iowa City, and I knew I'd have to look Donny up. I wanted him to know me as I was now, a professor, a published author, a person of some note, not that pantywaist of six years ago. Above all else, I wanted more of Donny Solomon. I don't know how else to say it. I wanted another story to tell. I wanted a bigger piece of him than the small one I already owned. I tried his number several times until a woman answered, late in the afternoon, and explained that Donny didn't live at that address anymore, that he and his wife had moved out of town to someplace called Stilton's Corner.
然后，在2002年的夏天，我发现自己回到了爱荷华城，我知道我必须去找唐尼。我想让他知道现在的我，一位教授、一位出版作家，一个有点名气的人，而不是六年前那个懦夫。最重要的是，我想要更多唐尼·所罗门的消息。我不知道该怎么说。我想要另一个故事来讲。我想要比我已经拥有的那小块更大的他。我试了他的号码几次，直到那天下午晚些时候，一个女人接了电话，解释说唐尼已经不住那个地址了，他和妻子搬出了城，搬到了一个叫斯蒂尔顿角（Stilton's Corner）的地方。
I followed the simple directions she had given me and ended up on a dirt road on the far south end of town. At a 90 degree turn in the road sat the yellow cinder block house she had promised. Its paint was peeling away in broad, curling flakes, and blooms of mildew had congregated like shadows along its soffits and eaves. It was early summer, and the milkweed pods along the rivers and ditches had opened and sent their cotton blowing, creating drifts along the margins of the road.
我按照她给我的简单指引，最终到了城南边的一条土路上。在道路90度转弯处，坐落着她所说的黄色煤渣块房子。漆皮大片大片地卷曲脱落，霉斑像阴影一样聚集在屋檐和屋檐下。那是初夏，河边和沟渠旁的马利筋果荚已经裂开，棉絮飘散，在路边形成了漂浮的薄层。
I had to kick through a mound of fluff to climb up the steps to the front door, and was about to knock when a woman pulled up in an old station wagon. She called out the window, "you the therapist?" I shook my head, and she cursed. She was a bony, narrow-hipped woman in a light blue, two-piece outfit, the kind worn by people who work in hospitals and old folks' homes. I introduced myself, explained that I was an old acquaintance of Donny Solomon's. And she told me her name was Tina, and that she was Donny's wife.
我不得不踢开一堆绒毛，爬上台阶走向前门，正准备敲门时，一个女人开着一辆旧旅行车停了下来。她在车窗外喊道：“你是治疗师吗？”我摇了摇头，她咒骂了一声。她是一个骨感、窄臀的女人，穿着浅蓝色两件套，那是医院和养老院工作人员常穿的那种衣服。我做了自我介绍，解释说我是唐尼·所罗门的一位老相识。她告诉我她叫蒂娜（Tina），是唐尼的妻子。
She pushed open the door and hustled me inside. I hesitated in the doorway, blinking, everything in the room a dim, massive shadow. A teenage girl rose from a couch. And there was a brief conversation and exchange of money, and the girl ducked past me without a word or glance, as if making an escape. A rough, phlegm-edged voice called out, "oh, the door. My god damn eyes."
她推开门，把我赶进屋内。我在门口犹豫了一下，眨着眼，房间里的每一件东西都沉浸在阴暗、巨大的阴影中。一个十几岁的女孩从沙发上站起来。接着是一段简短的对话和金钱交易，女孩没说一句话，也没回头，像是在逃离，从我身边溜走了。一个粗糙、带着痰音的声音喊道：“哦，门。我该死的眼睛。”
I pulled shut the door and peered into the dim room. Its most obvious feature was an old hospital bed, occupied by a grizzled, stick figure of a man, sunk to his waist in tangled sheets. He had the heels of his hands jammed into his eye sockets, and he was moaning in a thoughtless, almost distracted way. Tina moved quickly into the small kitchen, began slapping open cabinets and pulling drawers. "Baby doll," she spoke in the exaggerated tones typically used for small children or the hard of hearing, "somebody here to see you. Speak up, and try to be nice."
我关上门，凝视着阴暗的房间。它最明显的特征是一张旧病床，上面坐着一个灰白、干瘦如火柴棒的男人，腰部沉没在纠缠的被子里。他把双手掌根用力按进眼窝，心不在焉地呻吟着。蒂娜迅速走进小厨房，开始用力拍打柜子和抽屉。“宝贝，”她用通常对待小孩或听力不好的人那种夸张的语气说话，“有人来看你了。说话大声点，尽量友善些。”
Slowly, and with what seemed a great effort, the man lifted his face to look at me. From this angle, it was impossible not to notice the thin scar that started at his temple, made its way through his stiff, patchy hair, and ended in a curlicue behind his ear. He didn't speak, but his large, feverish eyes pulsed with what looked like the desire to communicate something uncommon and meaningful.
慢慢地，似乎费了很大劲，那个男人抬起脸看着我。从这个角度看，不可能不注意到那道薄薄的伤疤，从他的太阳穴开始，穿过他僵硬、斑驳的头发，在耳后结束。他没说话，但他巨大、发烧的眼睛里闪烁着某种渴望交流非同寻常且有意义的事情的光芒。
I was confused, even a little disoriented in that dark room, heavy with medicinal smells. "Is this Donny Solomon's house," I asked the old man. "Do you know if he's home?" The man opened his mouth, but couldn't seem to form it around the necessary syllables. On his second try, he said, "you are an [BLEEP] hole."
我感到困惑，甚至在那间充满药味、阴暗的房间里有点迷失方向。“这是唐尼·所罗门的家吗？”我问那个老人。“你知道他在家吗？”男人张开嘴，但似乎没法组成必要的音节。第二次尝试时，他说：“你是个[哔——]洞。”
"Donny," scolded Tina, who was now standing in the kitchen entryway. "You're going to scare him away." She brought in a shot glass full of at least a dozen pills and a silver can of Coors Light. She sighed. "I guess you didn't know about his accident? I don't think I'd have recognized him either. He's changed that much. Here, baby doll, I've got your pills."
“唐尼，”蒂娜斥责道，她现在正站在厨房门口。“你会把他吓跑的。”她拿来一个装了至少十几粒药片的酒杯和一罐银色的库尔斯淡啤酒（Coors Light）。她叹了口气。“我想你不知道他出了车祸？我想我也认不出他来。他变了这么多。来，宝贝，药给你。”
Nothing in this man's face, in his bony arms, or stiff, colorless hair recalled the oversized presence who'd shown up on my front deck six years before. Only the large, black widow tattoo on his neck, which now looked more like a nasty skin condition than anything menacing, convinced me that this was the same person. Tina sang a made-up nursery tune called "Pill Time," and began inserting the pills one by one into Donny's pursed lips.
这个男人的脸上、骨感的胳膊，或者僵硬、无色的头发里，没有任何东西能让人想起六年前出现在我前露台上的那个身材魁梧的身影。只有脖子上那巨大的黑寡妇纹身——现在看起来更像是一种讨厌的皮肤病，而不是什么威胁——让我确信这是同一个人。蒂娜唱了一首自编的名为“药片时间”的童谣，开始把药片一粒一粒地塞进唐尼紧闭的嘴唇里。
He seemed resigned to this indignity, until she held up the can of beer to his mouth, and he jerked forward, swatting the can out of her hand and scattering the remaining pills onto the bed and carpet. "My drink," he shouted, his voice thin with an infantile petulance. "My special drink!"
他似乎顺从于这种羞辱，直到她把啤酒罐举到他嘴边，他猛地前倾，把啤酒罐从她手中拍掉，剩下的药片洒在了床上和地毯上。“我的饮料，”他喊道，声音因为孩子气的任性而变得细弱。“我的特制饮料！”
"God damn you, Donny." Tina stood up, tensing her shoulders in a way that suggested she might strike him. Instead she held out her shirt, which was covered with flecks of beer foam. "Look at this," she cried, "I don't know how I stand it." She gave me a pained, apologetic look, holding out her wet hands. She told me that the only way Donny would take his pills these days was with his special drink, which they happened to be out of. She wondered if I wouldn't mind sitting with him while she ran down to the liquor store. "You two can catch up," she suggested, "talk about boy things."
“该死的你，唐尼。”蒂娜站起来，紧张地耸着肩膀，暗示她可能会打他。相反，她伸出被啤酒泡沫溅到的衬衫。“看看这个，”她哭道，“我不知道我怎么忍受的。”她给了我一个痛苦、抱歉的眼神，伸出湿漉漉的双手。她告诉我，唐尼这些日子服用药片的唯一方法就是配上他的特制饮料，而他们正好没货了。她问我是否介意在她去酒铺时陪陪他。“你们两个可以叙叙旧，”她建议，“聊聊男人的话题。”
On her way out the door, she let me know that Donny was subject to severe epileptic seizures, which is why he couldn't be left alone. "If something like that happens, go ahead and call 911. They'll tell you what to do." I made no move to stop her, only sat dumbly on the couch watching Donny, who spent most of his time trying to untangle his legs from the bedding.
在她出门时，她让我知道唐尼容易患严重的癫痫发作，这就是为什么他不能独自一人。“如果发生了这样的事，直接打911。他们会告诉你该怎么做。”我没阻止她，只是呆呆地坐在沙发上看着唐尼，他大部分时间都在努力把双腿从被子里解开。
"Can't figure this blanket out," he kept saying. He didn't seem much interested in me. And even though I knew it was pointless, I sat on the edge of his bed and asked him if he remembered how we'd first met, how he'd shown up at my door in the middle of the night. It didn't seem he was listening until I mentioned how drunk he must have been to get his car stuck so far off the main road. "I was not drunk," he spat, his voice dark with sudden menace. He pointed a wavering finger at me and told me that if I made such a claim again, he would not hesitate to break my neck.
“搞不定这条毯子，”他不停地说。他似乎对我不太感兴趣。虽然我知道这样做毫无意义，但我坐在他的床边，问他是否还记得我们第一次是怎么见面的，他如何在午夜时分出现在我的门口。他似乎没听进去，直到我提到他当时一定喝得有多醉，才会把车开得离主路那么远。“我没醉，”他喷着唾沫说，声音里带着突然的恶意。他颤抖着手指着我，告诉我如果我再提出这种主张，他会毫不犹豫地扭断我的脖子。
I abandoned the bed for the couch on the other side of the room. Even though he was about as harmless as a human being could be, I took him at his word. Right away, he got fidgety, his shoulders slumping with remorse. And he asked me to come back and talk to him some more. "Be nice, man," he said, "and I'll be nice too."
我放弃了床，坐在房间另一边的沙发上。虽然他看起来完全无害，但我相信了他的话。他立即变得焦躁不安，肩膀因懊悔而下垂。他让我回来和他多谈谈。“别这样，伙计，”他说，“对我好点，我也会对你好的。”
We didn't have much to say to each other after that. The late afternoon sun had sunk below the tree line, and a dusty light angled through the lowered blinds. Just when I was beginning to consider the idea that Tina had run off for good, leaving me to take over as Donny's sole guardian and caretaker, her old car rattled up the drive. Somewhere between here and the liquor store, she'd put on a flowery, rayon blouse and skirt and enough musky perfume to alert us of her presence before she came through the door, clutching two paper bags full of clinking bottles.
那之后我们没什么可说的。夕阳落到了树线以下，灰蒙蒙的光线从落下的百叶窗斜射进来。就在我开始考虑蒂娜是不是一去不回，让我接手成为唐尼唯一的监护人和看护人时，她的旧车嘎吱嘎吱地开进了车道。在从这里到酒铺的路上，她穿上了一件花哨的人造丝衬衫和裙子，洒了足够多的麝香香水，在进门之前就提醒我们她的存在，手里紧攥着两个装满叮当乱响瓶子的纸袋。
She called me back to the kitchen and asked me if I wanted to stay for dinner. "I got some fried chicken here, and I thought we'd do a macaroni salad," she said. I claimed that I wasn't hungry, but she waved me off. "We'll get us some drinks and then we'll have dinner. You can stay the night if you want. Donny won't mind. We don't get a lot of company here since his accident."
她叫我回厨房，问我愿不愿意留下来吃晚饭。“我买了炸鸡，我想我们再弄点通心粉沙拉，”她说。我推辞说我不饿，但她挥手拒绝了。“我们会喝几杯，然后吃饭。如果你愿意，可以留宿。唐尼不会介意的。自他出事后，我们这儿没什么客人。”
While I was trying to sort out what she meant by "stay the night," she got some water boiling for the pasta and told me the story of Donny's accident. It was the sort of absurdly tragic tale that fills you with guilty euphoria for having been spared the obscenities and injustices of this existence. About a year and a half ago, she explained, Donny had come out of one of his stints at the county lockup a changed man. He had been touched by God while in jail, and God had told him to change his ways. He joined AA, quit selling and smoking pot, said farewell to his many low-life friends. He cut his hair and got a job at the concrete plant. He decided he had a purpose in life, which was to reconnect to his daughter, April, a teenager who he had not seen since she was in kindergarten, having lost custody of her after the divorce with his first wife.
当我在试图理清她所说的“留宿”是什么意思时，她烧开了水煮意面，并向我讲述了唐尼车祸的故事。这是一种荒谬的悲剧故事，让人在因为免于这种存在的淫秽和不公而感到内疚的兴奋中充满罪恶感。大约一年半前，她解释说，唐尼在县监狱蹲了一段时间出来后，变成了一个全新的人。他在监狱里被上帝触动，上帝告诉他要改过自新。他加入了匿名戒酒互助会（AA），戒掉了卖和抽大麻，告别了他那许多卑劣的朋友。他剪了头发，在混凝土厂找了份工作。他决定他的人生目标是与女儿艾普尔（April）重新建立联系，那是他离婚后就没见过的十几岁女孩，他在与第一任妻子的离婚案中失去了监护权。
After he'd proven his honorable intentions, Donny was allowed a few brief visits with April, a movie, a trip to the mall, and finally a full day of Christian fellowship at Silverwood Lake with the New Life Missionary Baptist Church. Donny was so nervous about being with his daughter all day around Godly, upright people that he didn't sleep the entire night before. So nervous that, as some of those Godly, upright people later claimed, he had gone back to his car throughout the day to take snorts off a hidden bottle of whiskey.
在证明了自己的诚意后，唐尼被允许与艾普尔进行几次短暂的探访，看电影、去商场，最后是与新生命传教浸信会一起在银木湖（Silverwood Lake）度过整整一天的基督教团契日。唐尼对整天在虔诚、正直的人身边与女儿相处感到非常紧张，以至于前一天晚上整夜没睡。由于过度紧张，正如那些虔诚、正直的人后来声称的那样，他白天多次回到车里，从一瓶藏着的威士忌中偷喝。
Daddy and daughter drove home that night after a long day of weenie roasts and sack races and hymns sung by the fire. And Donny, drunk, exhausted, or some combination of the two, allowed the car to drift off the road and into a deep ravine, where it rolled, ejecting both of them into a stand of pines. The wreck was not discovered until the next morning. April died sometime during the night. And her father, despite shattered legs and pelvis, a broken back, ruptured liver, and irreversible brain damage, survived.
那晚在营火、麻袋比赛和火边赞美诗过了一整天后，父女俩开车回家。而喝醉了、精疲力竭或两者兼有的唐尼，允许车子偏离道路掉进了一个深沟里，车子翻滚，将两人甩进了一片松树林。直到第二天早上才发现车祸。艾普尔在夜间的某个时候去世了。而她的父亲，尽管腿部和骨盆破碎、脊椎骨折、肝脏破裂、大脑遭受不可逆损伤，却存活了下来。
"And that's where we are now," Tina said, giving me a wide, bright-eyed look of forced cheerfulness. "Donny out there with the mind of a 12-year-old and the ex-wife suing us for the clothes on our backs." She cackled and shook her head. "How [BLEEP] delightful." She took three jelly jars out of the freezer, poured a shot of vodka into each one, and filled them the rest of the way with cheap champagne. I accepted the drink and took a sip of it. I had never been much of a drinker, but this seemed like a reasonable time to start.
“这就是我们现在的处境，”蒂娜说着，给了我一个充满强颜欢笑的、大大的、明亮的眼神。“唐尼在那儿，拥有12岁孩子的智力，前妻还在起诉我们，要把我们身上的衣服都抢走。”她咯咯笑着摇了摇头。“多[哔——]有趣啊。”她从冷冻室拿出三个果冻罐，每个倒入一小杯伏特加，剩下的空间填满便宜的香槟。我接受了饮料，喝了一口。我一直不是个爱喝酒的人，但现在看来是开始喝酒的好时机。
We repaired to the front room, where Tina made a big production out of feeding Donny his remaining pills. And he gulped his drink like it was Gatorade. It didn't take him long to drink himself into a stupor. And eventually Tina edged over and sat next to me, so close that our hips and knees touched. A second later, her perfume settled on us like a fog bank. I pretended to sip my drink, and she watched me, turning slowly to show me her cleavage. "Now how did you and Donny meet," she said. "I never really got that part."
我们回到前厅，蒂娜大张旗鼓地给唐尼喂剩下的药片。他像喝佳得乐一样把酒喝了下去。没过多久他就喝得烂醉如泥。最终，蒂娜挪过来坐在我旁边，近得我们的臀部和膝盖碰到了一起。一秒钟后，她的香水味像一层迷雾笼罩着我们。我假装喝着酒，她看着我，慢慢转向我展示她的乳沟。“现在，你和唐尼是怎么认识的？”她说，“那部分我一直没太听懂。”
I started to tell her the story. I thought it might distract her from the life she had found herself in, make her laugh a little, maybe convince her to move her knee away from mine. But I couldn't go through with it. The words crumbled in my mouth, and I made up a lie about how Donny and I used to hang out at a bar downtown. I pulled out my wallet and produced the slip of paper with Donny's information, and when she saw it, her eyes went damp. "He was proud of his penmanship," she said, putting her hand on my shoulder. "He wrote like a [BLEEP] girl."
我开始给她讲那个故事。我以为这可能会让她分心，不去想她现在的生活，让她笑一笑，也许能说服她把膝盖从我旁边移开。但我没法继续讲下去。单词在我的嘴里崩溃了，我编了个谎话，说我和唐尼过去常在城里的酒吧鬼混。我掏出钱包，出示了那张写着唐尼信息的纸条，当她看到它时，眼睛湿润了。“他为自己的字迹感到自豪，”她说，把手放在我的肩膀上。“他写字像个[哔——]女孩。”
Donny had been watching us closely the entire time. He shifted a little, made a noise in the back of his throat, "Teeny, come back," he called out weakly, barely moving his lips. "Come back over here." "Oh, baby doll," she said, and crawled onto the bed and cooed over and petted him, nuzzled his neck and kissed his stubbly head. I sat on the couch, took a few more fake sips of my drink, and decided that I couldn't stand watching them, couldn't be a part of this anymore. I asked to use the bathroom, and hurried down the narrow hall and locked the door behind me.
唐尼一直在仔细盯着我们。他稍微动了一下，喉咙里发出一种声音，“蒂尼，回来，”他虚弱地叫道，嘴唇几乎没动。“过来这里。”“哦，宝贝，”她说，爬上床，对他轻声细语，爱抚着他，磨蹭他的脖子，亲吻他长满胡茬的头。我坐在沙发上，假装又喝了几口，决定我受够了看着他们，我不能再参与进来了。我借口上厕所，匆匆跑下狭窄的走廊，关上门锁好。
I sat on the carpeted toilet lid and rehearsed my exit speech. I wanted it to be compassionate and dignified, so I could make my escape cleanly, without ugliness or hurt feelings. It took me another minute to find my nerve. When I came out, I found Tina and Donny dozing against each other, both clutching empty jelly jars. I didn't have to think about it. I went straight for the door, walking with such exquisite care that I felt cushions of air under my feet.
我坐在铺着地毯的马桶盖上，排练我的离别词。我想让它富有同情心且庄重，这样我就可以干净利落地逃脱，不留丑陋或伤人的感觉。又过了一分钟我才鼓起勇气。出来时，发现蒂娜和唐尼靠在一起打盹，手里都紧攥着空的果冻罐。我不需要考虑，我径直走向门，走得如此小心翼翼，感觉脚下垫着空气垫。
As I passed the bed, Donny opened his eyes to look at me, which stopped me cold. And only when he gave me a little nod, the slightest dip of his head, did I reach for the doorknob and slip out into the warm evening. I hurried across the yard, stepping over the drifts of milkweed fluff. And by the time I made it to the road, I felt a hot stab of shame. Not for sneaking away like some kind of Judas, or for abandoning these people, but for not needing them any longer. Donny Solomon was useless to me now, nothing more than a sad, baffled soul. Just like me.
当我经过床边时，唐尼睁开眼睛看着我，这让我彻底僵住了。直到他给了我一个点头，极其微小的点头，我才够到门把手，滑进温暖的夜晚。我匆匆穿过院子，跨过马利筋绒毛堆。到了路上时，我感到一阵火辣的羞耻感。不是因为像犹大一样偷偷溜走，也不是因为遗弃了这些人，而是因为我不再需要他们了。唐尼·所罗门现在对我毫无用处，只不过是一个悲伤、困惑的灵魂。就像我一样。
Brady Udall in Teasdale, Utah. He's the author of the novel The Miracle Life of Edgar Mint.
布雷迪·尤达尔，在犹他州蒂斯代尔。他是小说《埃德加·薄荷的奇迹生活》（The Miracle Life of Edgar Mint）的作者。
Special thanks today to Steve Keshket and Jennifer Murgey and Emily Voight who co-produced our story about Tim Jaccard. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
今天特别感谢史蒂夫·凯什凯特（Steve Keshket）、詹妮弗·默吉（Jennifer Murgey）和艾米丽·沃伊特（Emily Voight），他们合力制作了我们关于蒂姆·雅卡德的故事。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助信息]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Torey Malatia, who says he has a very good reason for showing up so late to our broadcast today.
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督者，我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia），他说他今天在直播中迟到有一个非常好的理由。
"I'm partying with this guy Peanut. Maybe you've heard of him. And the next thing I know, my car is sunk up to the axles in a dry lakebed. What the [BLEEP], right?"
“我和这个叫花生的家伙聚会。也许你听说过他。下一件事我就知道，我的车在干涸的湖床上陷到车轴了。搞什么[哔——]，对吧？”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。